نعم ، لقد شاهدنا في اليومين الماضيين
مقاطع فيديو جيك لجنود روسيين داخل
تلك المدينة يقودون السكان المحليين
تحت تهديد السلاح يقتحمون المتاجر التي
تملأ عربات التسوق ، لقد رأينا للتو منشورًا على
فيسبوك من قبل رئيس بلدية
المدينة وهو يشير إلى أنه
أبرم نوعًا من التعامل مع ما أشار إليه
بالمسلح ، كما اقترح أيضًا أن
القوات المسلحة وبهذا أعتقد أنه يعني
أن القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية قد غادرت المدينة في الواقع
، فإنه يحدد ما يبدو أنه
يجب أن يقول الأحكام العرفية وفرض حظر التجول.
يُسمح فقط بالتنقل في جميع أنحاء
المدينة خلال النهار ، حيث يمكن للمشاة المشي
واحدًا تلو الآخر وبحد أقصى اثنين ،
ويجب أن يتوقفوا عند الطلب الأول
أفترض أنه من الجنود الروس
هناك ، من الواضح أن الجيش الروسي
له وجود كبير داخل
المدينة.  سمعنا في إحاطة البنتاغون
للتو والإيحاء بأن المدينة
لا تزال محل خلاف
من السكان الذين تحدثنا إليهم ،
فقد صمتت الأسلحة قبل عدة ساعات
وقد لا يكون ذلك في جميع أنحاء العالم
المدينة نفسها
ولكنها ذات أهمية استراتيجية
تقع بجوار الجسر الحيوي الذي
أبلغنا عنه والذي يأتي من شبه جزيرة
القرم ويبدو من قراءة
البيان الصادر عن رئيس البلدية أن نوعًا
من الترتيبات قد قام به مع
ما هو عليه  يشير إلى الرجال المسلحين
داخل تلك المدينة ، وهو يقول بشكل أساسي
في البيان أنه إذا
تم استيفاء هذه الشروط ، فلا يزال بإمكان العلم الأوكراني أن يطير
أه يرث على الرغم من أنني يجب أن
أشير إليكم ، فقد سمعنا
تصريحات سابقة من مسؤولين محليين في
الماضي بشكل خاص حول
حالة الجسر والتي تجاوزتها
الأحداث ، خاصة عندما
تراجعت القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية ، يجب أن
أقول على الرغم من مقاطع الفيديو التي
رأيناها خلال الـ 24-48 ساعة الماضية ،
فإنها تشبه إلى حد كبير الجيش الروسي
لديهم سيطرة كبيرة على
ابنهم وهذا المنشور على Facebook يشير أيضًا إلى
أنه قد يكون هناك مكان للإقامة ،
وإن كان يبدو كثيرًا مثل
الاحتلال في ظل الأحكام العرفية ب  لقد كانت القوات الروسية
مع رئيس البلدية مجرد البداية على
الرغم من أنني أفكر في ما نراه هنا
في الجنوب ، إلا أننا كنا واضحين أنه
بينما كان هناك توقف في أه
التقدم العسكري الروسي في شمال
البلاد ، فقد رأوا  يبدو أن الزخم الأفضل
في الهيرزوغ الجنوبي
يتغير في الميكروفون الديناميكي على قيد الحياة في
البلدة التالية المدينة الرئيسية التالية إلى
غربها التي هي مسرح
قتال عنيف على الرغم من أنه يبدو أنها
تسيطر على
أوكرانيا في اللحظة التي سمعنا فيها صفارات الإنذار المستمرة  مباشرة
بعد الغسق هنا لبعض الوقت ، مخاوف حقيقية من
أن هذه الصور المتداولة
للسفن الحربية الروسية على الساحل والتي لم يتم
التحقق منها ولكن يبدو أنها تتوافق مع
التصريحات الرسمية الأوكرانية بأن
السفن الحربية الروسية قبالة الساحل هنا
قد تكون تنذر
بالغزو البرمائي هنا.  حذر العديد من
المسؤولين الغربيين من أنه قد يكون
جزءًا من الخطة الروسية الأوسع نطاقًا ، حيث
لا يمكنك التحكم في أوكرانيا
واقتصادها دون أوديسا وهذه المدينة
شديدة الغموض  ح على الحافة جيك أين
جناح كلاريسا في كييف أوكرانيا نيك بايتون
والش وأوديسا أوكرانيا بفضل كلاكما ،
يرجى البقاء آمنًا
لك